how intense is John Bernthal he's a
great Punisher he's a kid I met him once
and he was really sweet but he's got
this intensity and all his roles that
I'm just like
I remember he
told me a story he was working with
Sylvester Stallone yeah
and Sylvester said he was boxing and
Sylvester Stallone came in and bought
like took his something it was his rosin
or rosin I don't know what it was but
it's something you don't do and he goes
hey what are you doing he still honestly
what it would
and he says you know better than anybody
that you don't take that from another
boxers like you know you're absolutely
right I'm sorry about that you put it
back down and it got a little intense
but like he told me some great stories
but he's uh about meeting Robert De Niro
yeah anyone did he ever tell you that
stuff no he didn't tell me he wanted to
meet Robert Jr after they worked
together uh-huh and at the end he goes
look I waited the whole time I just want
to say well De Niro goes
why don't you let's come the trail I
have to have a drink whatever I don't do
De Niro only comes in the trailer and
um Bernthal kind of says I love the
story he says you know De Niro's
thinking they're just gonna have a drink
and two guys hanging out right and
bernthal's like I just gotta say this
you're my idol man I mean I I you're
he's yeah you don't have to do this and
you can tell De Niro's really
uncomfortable he's like no no I wanted
to I want to say this I guess it's on
this so you know you don't need to do
this it's like no I have to say this
he's like okay
and he just went on about how much he
loved him and how it meant to him
working with him and how he's acting and
I go so then he loved it right he goes
no it was the most uncomfortable awkward
[ __ ] thing that ever happened in my
life yeah but but is he intense
um yeah I mean certainly he can be you
know um but I generally especially with
me I would say I can only speak from our
relationship he was supportive he was
Lifted Me Up he always talked about how
excited he was to work with me how much
he wanted me to cross over and do the
work with him on Punisher we would still
love to work together on other things in
the future you know so I I have a lot of
love and respect for John so he he's
great great actor great actor great
um and you know and and I always said
John's John's failing is actually how
great of an actor he is or not his
failing but his you know his Achilles
heel maybe is that because you know
we'll read a script and you know most
actors we go oh yeah this is good you
get really excited about the thing and
sometimes that blinds you a little bit
to some of the logic of the scene
because you can just like suspension of
disbelief just skate right by it not
John
John will read something and he'll be
like okay he's good so but why why would
I give her the gun you know and you're
like oh why why would he you know and
suddenly you're like oh yeah that
doesn't make any sense why are we doing
and then suddenly you've got an hour on
set where you're trying to figure out
what you're gonna do instead kind of
thing kind of because John is too good
at what he does